g develop is a 2d cross platform free
and open source game engine
wesley and max teach this course they're
both game developers and teachers and
this course is the best way to get
started with g develop
hey there my name is wesley and this is
max
and we're going to take you from zero
knowledge to releasing a game with g
develop in this video
i'm going to start us off with the
general layout of
[Music]
gdevelop when you first download g
develop you'll be met with this screen
from here you can open an existing
project or start a brand new one
when you click on create a new project
you'll be given a bunch of options for
starter games and examples we're gonna
skip all those for now and just go
straight for a blank game
when you start from scratch like this
you need to add a new scene which is
where you'll actually make the game
to keep things organized it's important
to make sure that you give your scenes
appropriate titles
since we opened a blank game project we
need to open some of the panels
up here in the top right corner you'll
see some of the options
you'll also have the ability to add a
grid to your game project to help
organize things and to change the level
of zoom
let's start with the object panel this
is where you're going to import and
manage your game objects
everything from your characters to your
tiles to
your particle effects will all show up
in this panel
we'll start by creating a sprite the
most commonly used game object
you should make sure to give this a
title that makes sense
click add an animation
find the art that you want to use
and open it be sure to click apply to
save any work that you've done
and then you can just drag the object
straight from the panel into the game
space
you can drag to click on multiple
objects at a time and use the middle
mouse button to move the scene around
and zoom in and out
the next panel over is for object groups
it's a useful tool that lets you target
a group of objects as opposed to each
individual one when you want to do
things with them for example i could
have a bunch of
hearts and potions and food items and
call all of them healing items and then
i could make a single event that makes
it so that if the player is in collision
with one of those healing items they get
healed
instead of making a different event for
every single item in the list
next up is the properties panel when
this panel is open and you click on an
object you'll get to see their position
z order angle and so on
and from this panel you can actually
control all of those things
moving them around changing their angle
and changing their z order
which is what decides whether an object
is behind or in front of another one
and that's a good transition to talking
about layers
with the layers panel you can create
different layers to place objects on
so you can create a foreground
mid-ground and background as well as ui
layers and menu layers
typically you'll put most of your game
objects on the base layer and have that
camera following the player while having
all of your ui objects and menus on
different layers where the camera is
stationary
from this panel you can also add effects
to layers edit their properties
and toggle their visibility
back to the properties panel
you can also use this panel to resize
objects
but be careful while doing this because
changing an image's resolution can
really make it blurry
the last panel is for the instance list
this can be a useful tool for finding
where things are in your game project
especially once they've gotten so big
that you can't tell where things are
anymore
you'll notice these window tabs up top
the start page and then your main scene
page
where all of the game building is done
and then that scenes event list
where all of the black magic happens but
we'll get to that in another video
up in the top left you can open your
project manager and in the game settings
you'll find properties this is where
you'll do things like change the game's
name give it a version number a package
name an author log in with your profile
and change the game's resolution which
is something you should definitely do
because very few devices are defaulted
to 800x600
you can also tell the engine here how to
expand the game to meet the size of the
screen that it's in
as well as tweaking the max and min
frame rates that the game will run at
for mobile devices you can choose
whether the game runs in portrait mode
or landscape mode and then you can turn
on and off anti-aliasing the only real
reason you would turn this feature off
is if your game uses pixel art
and if your game is running ads then
this is where you would slot in your app
id
you can also edit the game's initial
loading screen from here
the rest of the project game settings
has global variables which we'll get to
at another time
icons which are your desktop and
mobile app icons
and resources which is where you can go
to see all the assets that are in your
game file
there are a few options here that you
might need
like when individual objects are blurry
or if an object or sound effect is
stuttering before it loads in
the rest of the project tab has
the scenes that we've already talked
about external events and layouts which
we plan to explain in another video
and then functions and behaviors and if
you wanted to use the pre-built
extensions that include things like
giving the enemies health and different
movement systems then this would be the
place to get those
and we're going to tackle that in
another video as well
let's close this project and open one of
the starter games
you'll see that all of the game's
objects have loaded into the objects
panel as well as the events and the game
itself
now in the top left corner
the two last things to talk about are
the export button which is what you
would use when you're finished building
your game and you want to release it to
the public and the preview button which
is what you would use to play test your
own game
when you click this button it will play
from whichever scene you're on currently
it'll open up a window and i can just
play
one last thing though before you go
this is something that i didn't know
about even though i've used the engine
for over two years
and you see all these panels they can
all move
now this isn't revolutionary but this
does allow you to customize your
workspace and set it up so that it works
best for you
though this is probably not how the
developers thought people would use it
next i'm going to go over the object
types in gdevelop
[Music]
we start off with a basic scene and on
the right hand side you'll see the
objects that i've imported into the game
we're going to click on add a new object
and from here you're going to see all
the options
we're going to begin though with the
most commonly used object which is a
sprite
which we already have labeled in the
scene as the player
sprites are able to have different
animations where you add in each frame
of the animation pick the speed that the
animation plays at and decide whether or
not it should loop
you can also label animations to make
them easier to use later
to add more animations to a sprite just
click add an animation
down here in the bottom left corner you
can edit the sprite's collision mask
you can also edit points that are on the
sprite on the bottom left hand side as
well
every object can be given behaviors and
effects
behaviors are pre-built game logic that
you can use to help make your game
faster
so if we give the player character the
platformer behavior
you can see there's a bunch of numbers
in here that you can tweak but you can
leave those as default if you want to
and then if we give the player character
the drop shadow effect we get a
character that has a drop shadow and one
that can move when you press the arrow
keys
a quick side note for the platformer
behavior if you don't give the ground
that they're standing on the platform
behavior then your character will just
fall out of the screen
speaking of the ground
let's move on to the next object which
is a tiled sprite we use tiled sprites
because if you grab a regular sprite and
try to change its size it will scale
whereas tiled sprites will duplicate
instead of changing size so you can use
this for a bunch of different things
like level design and ui
the next object type is text you can
change the size color and font of this
object and then write in whatever you
would like to to fill it in
and then you can use the event system to
change what's written in this object
during your game
next up is the particle emitter you can
use the particle emitter for a whole
range of things but the two most
important parts are
particle kind which come in point line
and texture
texture being one that you can import
yourself to create whatever kind of
particle you want and the number of
particles in tank
if this is set to negative one the
particle emitter will stay there forever
in your game if it's set to a positive
number then it will use that many
particles and then stop
you can either place them in scene to
start when the scene starts or use the
event system to spawn them wherever you
need them
next is the nine patch panel sprite you
import an image
and then it's easiest to show you this
from the wiki you put the size of your
margins into the nine patch panel sprite
and then it will expand in the way that
you see on screen
maintaining the ratios of the outside
edges
and this can be used for dialog boxes ui
design and a bunch of different things
the shape painter is also easiest to
explain from the example in the wiki
basically this can be used to create a
range of shapes for ui waypoints
selection tools and things like that
the text entry object is used to enter
text you create the object put it in
scene and then using this simple event
and the hello world text object that we
made earlier the game will record and
display what i'm typing into my keyboard
next is the bb text which is very
similar to the basic text object but
you're able to do more things with fonts
and effects
if you don't need to use these effects
you're better off just using the basic
text object
the light object can be used to create
some dynamic shadows
i just create the object place it in
scene and then give the player character
the light obstacle behavior and then you
can see that the light is being
obstructed by the player's collision
mask that we set up earlier
the last object type video is pretty
straightforward you just pick the
video's opacity volume and then import
the video
it's best to use an mp4 for
compatibility reasons
and then you can control the stopping
and starting of the video through the
event system
now that that's out of the way we can
start talking about the event system
[Music]
we'll begin with a scene that i've set
up and go into the event sheet
from here we can add an event
and we'll zoom in to make it more
readable
so the easiest way to think of the no
code system
is to think of if then
so if this side the condition side
is true
then
this side
the action side
will happen
so i'm going to set up a simple event
i'm going to search for key pressed and
then type in d
and then for an action
i could search for this again
but i can also click on an object
and it will give me a list of things
that will only relate to that object i
could search down this list to find the
things that i want
but because i know what i want i'm just
going to type in force
and select add a force
i'm going to give it a positive power in
the x direction and then 0 in the y
direction and i'm going to leave it at
instant because an instant force will
only apply while the condition is true
whereas a permanent force will stay with
that object permanently and now when i
press preview and hold down the d key
the player object will very slowly move
to the right back in the event sheet i
can add more events by clicking here
here or by right clicking and selecting
new event
now i can drag this event over and turn
it into a sub event of our original
event i'll add the action rotate select
the player and give it an angular speed
i'm also going to increase the speed for
the apply force event
and now when i press d the character
rotates and moves faster
what's happening is
the main event is being checked to see
if its conditions are true and if those
conditions are true then it will move
down and check the sub events
but if we drag this event over and turn
it back into a regular event it has no
conditions
so when we preview the game now the
character will be rotating constantly
but still when i press the d key it'll
move over
i can copy and paste existing events
rather than just constantly creating new
ones and then i can modify this to make
it affect a different object
realizing that this might be a little
hard to see i'm going to create one
final event
i could click on other conditions and
manually search for the condition that i
need but since i know what i want
already i'm just going to search for at
the beginning of scene
which is a condition that only triggers
once at the beginning of the scene
and then i'll add zoom camera and type
in 2.
you can delete individual actions and
conditions by selecting them and
pressing delete as well as entire events
and then you can press ctrl z or control
y to undo or redo anything you've done
you can right-click an event and move it
into a group
groups are useful to help organize your
project
giving these appropriate names is
incredibly important
there are a few other things that you
can add to your event sheet like
comments which will help you label your
game events to remind you of what each
one does
a couple of the more useful event types
that you can add are for each object
which is an event that will repeat every
frame for every object of that type in
the game so if i have 20 player objects
in the game then it will repeat for all
20 player objects
another commonly used event type is
repeat
which as the name implies is one that
you can set up to repeat x number of
times per frame
and speaking of per frame
the engine reads the event list once per
frame
if you go to the project manager you can
see that the game is defaulted to force
the game to run between 20 frames per
second and 60 frames per second
you can edit those if you need to
but i would generally leave this alone
let's quickly talk about organization
and i'll show you why it's important
after
if we open up one of the starter games
that you can use
you can see how nicely set up everything
is with comments and sub events
set up to make sure that it's easy to
understand at a glance rather than
having to read every event to see what
each one does
but you can further organize your game
using groups
to group everything together
you can then pick a color for the group
header
and comments
to show you why organization is so
important i'll open up the events for a
game jam game that i made
if you don't organize your events from
the beginning you'll find it getting out
of hand
really quickly
till you get to the point where it's
almost impossible to fix anything in
your game because you don't know where
the event is
you can use the search bar to try to
find it but sometimes that's just not
enough
and now that we have an event
complicated enough to show you how this
works i'm going to really quickly go
over how the engine checks events
so every frame the event list is checked
but it checks the event list from top to
bottom
checking each condition from top to
bottom and then if that condition is
true
then
all of these actions will happen from
top to bottom
now that you know the basics of the
event system i can go over all the tools
that gdevelop has integrated into the
engine to help you jump right into
making games
when you open gdevelop you'll be given
the option to create a new project or
open an existing one
if you click on create new project
you'll see a list of starter games and
examples that you can learn from and
build off of which are all under the mit
license
which means that you're free to use
anything here
for your projects that are just for fun
or commercially
if we go back to these starter games and
click on one you can see that it's
loaded in all of the objects and events
required for this game
if i click on preview i can just play
this game as is
most of these starter games are just the
base logic you need for that type of
game so they'll usually only have one
example level in them but you can build
on those if you want to
if we go back to the game that i was
using in the previous video
i can show you behaviors
behaviors are pre-built logic that will
help you make your games faster
you'll see that there's a bunch of these
that come with the engine
but we also have community built
behaviors
created by other game developers that
you can find by clicking here and
searching those behaviors
a quick side note here
these community built behaviors are the
same thing as community built extensions
the only difference being that they're
filtered to only show you the ones that
apply to the object
if you'd like to see the full list of
extensions you can find that here
if we go back to the default behaviors
we can click on top down movement
and turn off rotation
and then we have a character that'll
move around on screen when i press the
arrow keys
so now if i go back in i can add another
behavior and i'm going to pick draggable
object
so now i've got a character that can
move around with the arrow keys
and i can drag it around with the
mouse but now that i'm done with those i
can delete them
and now we'll talk about piskel
the engine's built-in image editor
i've mostly used this to correct the
orientation of an image by flipping it
or rotating it but you can use this to
make brand new images or to edit
existing ones
next up is the sound creation tool jfxr
if you put in the action play a sound
you'll see a prompt that will let you
open up jfxr a tool that can be used to
create a range of different sounds by
manually correcting sliders
or by randomizing them like this
next up is the engine's asset library
if you click on add a new object
you can click here to create one from
scratch
or you can search the asset library
which is currently a manually curated
collection of art assets that you can
freely use in your games
when you click on an asset that you like
you'll be able to see which artist
created it and what license the assets
are under
you can click on the license to be
brought to a page that will explain the
license to you
the cc0 license for example
means that you're allowed to use these
assets in your game whether it be
commercial or not without having to
credit the artist
other assets in the library though might
be under a different license that would
require you to credit the artist
if you like a particular piece of art
you can click on the name of the artist
and it'll bring you to more works by the
artist
this for example is kenny art
which is an artist whose work i'm
actually using right now
so to continue using their art i'm going
to grab this background tile click to
add it to the game
and then i'm going to create a
background layer and put the image on it
making sure to put the background layer
below the base layer so it's behind it
and tada
my game now has a more interesting
background
so those are some of the tools that g
develop has brought together to help you
in jump starting the game making process
you've got starter games and examples
built-in and community built behaviors
piskel for image editing jfxr to help
you with your sound effects and the
assets library
so if i give the player character
the platformer behavior
give the ground the platform behavior
and we'll give the b
the physics engine 2.0 behavior
and then for giggles we'll give the
ground
the physics behavior as well
for the next portion max is going to
take over and explain how variables work
in g develop
[Music]
so variables are used whenever you want
to store some information about your
game for example maybe the player's
health or the player's score
in gdevelop a variable can live in one
of three places
it can live in the scene which is useful
for things like a level score that is
explicitly tied to a particular scene
it can live on the object which is
useful for things like enemy health that
are tied to particular objects in this
case enemies or it can live globally
which is useful for things like say a
player selected username that needs to
be accessed from everywhere within your
project
let's start by taking a look at scene
variables
as you can see we have here a basic
platformer however when we go to pick up
a coin the score does not increase
we can fix this using variables
start by going to the scene properties
and then clicking on the edit scene
variables button
here you can view all of your scene
variables and also add new ones
we'll start by adding a new score
variable and setting its initial value
to zero
then when the player collides with a
coin
we'll add a new change a scene variable
action
which adds to the variable score the
value 1.
then we add a new action without a
condition which modifies the scene text
object
we'll use the variable string function
which allows us to access a scene
variable from anywhere
and then specify the score variable and
then finally put the text score in front
using the concatenation or plus operator
to join the text with the variable
sure enough our score counter is now
working as intended
next let's take a look at object
variables
right now our slime enemy does not move
and what we'd like is for it to move
back and forth between these two markers
we can start by opening the drop down
menu on the slime object and selecting
the edit object variables option
this will give us a list of all of our
object variables on this particular
object
we can start by adding a new direction
variable with an initial value of left
then in our event sheet we can add to
the slime a text of an object variable
action which sets the direction to left
we call this when the slime is inclusion
with the left marker and then we can do
the same thing for the right as well
we can then use the text of an object
variable condition to test the direction
variable
when it's left we'll incorporate our
game logic for moving the slime to the
left in this case adding a force and
setting the flip state
and then we can do the same for the
right direction as well
and now our slime is no longer
stationary
note that while we've written all of the
events ourselves for this example to
demonstrate variables there's plenty of
great behaviors out there to do this for
you we should have a video on behavior
soon if that is foreign to you
finally let's take a look at global
variables
let's say that our platformer has
multiple levels
if we look at the score as we transition
between these levels you'll see that it
resets
while this may be what we want we also
might want more of a global score that
stays the same when we transition
between two levels
we can start by going to the project
manager where we will find the global
variables button
then we can add the score variable much
like we did earlier for the scene
now all we have to do is change our
scene variable action to the
corresponding global one
and then replace our variable string
function with the global variable string
function
and now sure enough our score will carry
on through a scene transition
very nice
now that we've gotten through variables
i can show you the expression builder
so to begin with i'll show you where the
expression builder is
we go to the event sheet and pick an
action
we pick the b enemy and select rotate
and trust me the engine can do a lot
more things than just rotate an object
but it just seems like the thing that i
picked the most
if i put a 1 in here the b enemy will
rotate at an angular speed of 1
but if i go to the expression builder
here on the right
you'll see there's a big list of things
i can search from
these can range from the size and width
of an object to the distance between two
objects
which i'm going to use now
you'll see that i've multiplied it by
one
and that's just to show you that this
basically works the same way as an
algebra equation when you're sticking to
numbers
so you can add subtract multiply divide
use brackets
the whole nine yards
and then if we go back to the main scene
and give the player object the draggable
object behavior and we press preview
we can then drag the player closer to
the b and as we do that you can see it's
slowing down
and that's because the distance between
the b and the player object is getting
smaller so it's rotating at a slower
speed
but if we move the player away from the
b it speeds back up again because it's
getting further away so the number is
bigger
now let's get rid of that and i'll show
you an actual game related example
so i made these objects earlier we have
a heart object that's a sprite and a
heart object that's a tile sprite
so if we put the tiled sprite into the
scene
within the camera's default border
and then put it on the ui layer that i
made earlier
then we can build this first event
where when i release the left mouse
button
one time
we'll create the heart sprite object at
the x and y position of the mouse
then we'll make a second event with the
condition
if player is in collision with heart
and then we'll make the action to modify
the object variable of the player
if we click on this tool button to the
right we'll be shown this object's
object variable list and since it didn't
have any i'm going to click add
and give it an object variable of health
and then 2 as the number
so now when i click here it'll show me
my options and i'll select add
because what i'm trying to do is add to
the player's health and one
and then i'm going to create an action
that shows that the player's health has
changed
so if i select the heart ui object
and select the width of the object
i'll select it to set 2
and then click on the expression builder
tool
search for object and select object
variable
select the player as the object
and you can see i can click here again
to display this object's variables
i'm going to select health
and because i know the size of the heart
that i made earlier it's 64 pixels by 64
pixels i'm going to multiply this width
by 64.
this is only going to work because it's
a tile sprite if i pick the regular
heart object which is a sprite it would
just get all squished up
now let's move this into its own event
so it's checking this every frame
and then as a final action we're going
to add delete the heart
and just to show you that the player
doesn't have to be the thing that gets
the platformer controls
you can literally put these behaviors on
any object
i'm gonna put it on the heart
so what's happening here is that each
frame we're changing the heart ui's size
to match the player's health
and every frame that the left mouse
button is released will create one heart
object at the mouse position
and every frame that the player is in
collision with a heart it will add one
to the object variable health of the
player object
and then it will delete that heart
so now if we press preview you'll see
the health ui is up at the top showing
two hearts because it's expanded to two
times 64 because the player's object
variable health starts at two
and now if i release the left mouse
button it creates a heart at the x and y
coordinates of the mouse
and it does this every time i click
if i drop one directly on the player
you'll see that it's added one to the
object variable health
because it's being displayed up top
and it will keep adding health as long
as i keep giving it hearts
in the next portion max is going to go
over extensions
you'll see here i've made a fairly
simple dungeon crawler with one enemy
and one piece of treasure to find as it
stands though our game leaves a lot to
be desired for example maybe we want to
be able to hold down our mouse and shoot
at a fixed cooldown rather than having
to click a button each time
maybe we want a smart enemy that can
pathfind around walls to get to us
rather than just running into them and
maybe we'd like the one to point at the
cursor for a more interactive gameplay
experience we could try to implement
this functionality ourselves or we can
use functions and behaviors known more
broadly as extensions extensions allow
us as game creators to spend less time
reinventing the wheel and more time
actually making our game as an added
bonus you'll find that using extensions
leads to a much cleaner event sheet
which will help a lot as your project
grows
so let's take a look at how to use
them we can get started with behaviors
by opening the drop down menu for an
object and selecting the edit behaviors
menu option
you can then add a behavior with the add
a behavior button and then you'll be
presented with a list of built-in
behaviors native to do develop there's
also a plethora of community-made
behaviors available through the search
new behaviors option
for this project we'll select the fire
bullets behavior and install it
and then we'll see it in our list of new
behaviors we can then add it to our
object by clicking on it
and then we'll find the behavior
properties here these give us some more
control over how the behavior will act
so in this case we can set the cooldown
when we fire a bullet
now when we select our object in the
event sheet we'll find that it's been
basically supercharged with new
abilities
in this case our wad now has a fire a
bullet action which we can use to fire
bullets towards the mouse
now another problem with our game is
that
well
our ai is a little bit more a than i
we can fix this by implementing
pathfinding which is just another
behavior in our list but with a behemoth
of a behavior property list
we'll go over how to actually implement
this in a future video
finally in addition to behaviors there
are also functions which can be accessed
from the project properties panel
followed by opening the function slash
behaviors menu this is where you can
find community made functions as well as
behaviors as for using functions well
there are a lot like behaviors but
they're not tied to specific objects
they can do things like for example
align stuff in your scene or in the case
of this project rotate a wand about a
character and point it at the cursor
looks much better now don't you think
now that we've gone through everything
that i consider to be the basics we're
going to build a game more specifically
we're going to recreate asteroids
[Music]
i won't be showing you how i'm creating
these events
just the ones that i'm using
but i will be showing you what i'm doing
so to begin with i'm going to be using
the space shooter redux pack
and i'm going to jump right into a blank
game project
i'll create a new scene
and i'll create a sprite object
named player for this example i'm going
to take advantage of the physics
behavior that comes with g develop by
default
and i'm going to start by leaving
everything alone except for changing the
gravity to zero so that the object
doesn't just fall out of the sky
so now we'll move over to the event
sheet and start with a player movement
with the condition
if the w key is pressed
and then the action apply a physics
force towards the angle the player is
facing
and then i'm going to move the origin of
the sprite into the center so that we
can use that origin point as the point
where forces will be applied
and then we'll copy our condition for
our first event and then paste those for
the a and d key presses
and then we'll apply a torque to the
player object based on which key is
being pressed
take note this is not just the rotate
and object action
this is apply a torque it's specific to
the physics behavior
and i'm using this because i want to
make sure that all of the forces are
being applied using the same kind of
rules
and now
i have a character that spins out of
control
the problem here is that the sprite is
in the wrong orientation so i'm going to
open up piskel change its orientation
and then save it
with that part fixed i'm going to move
on to firing bullets
using the conditions when the spacebar
is released
and once
and as you can see i've created the
bullet object already
and since the bullet is a really bright
color i'm going to change the background
of the scene to black so it stands out
better
and now for the bullet we put the action
create object and add a force and rotate
object
but moving the rotate action above the
apply a force action because we want to
make sure that it's rotated before it
starts moving
and the bullet's orientation is off just
like the players was so i could go into
piskull and change the orientation of
the bullet just like i did with the
player or
i can add 90 degrees to the rotation and
change it so that the player's angle is
the thing that tells it which direction
to go
and after we tweak the origin of the
bullet just like we did the player
it works just fine
though i do have to change the z order
so that the bullet spawns below the
player and not on top
and that's the player basically done
next we'll make another event for the
beginning of scene where we're going to
change the center of the camera to the
zero point
and change the zoom to 0.5
changing the camera to the zero point
was so that we could easily do screen
wrap and zooming the camera out was just
so that we would have a better scale for
an asteroids game
now let's add some asteroids
we'll add in some animations
and give them the physics 2.0 behavior
place a couple in scene
and we'll do that again with medium and
small asteroids
and now because everything has the
physics behavior i can start knocking
things around like marbles
and just like in asteroids we're gonna
make it so that when you shoot an
asteroid it blows up into smaller parts
so we'll create a for each instance
event where the object being picked is
the big asteroid
use the condition
if bullet is in collision with asteroid
then we will create two medium asteroids
give them a random rotation
and then apply a force in whichever
direction they're facing
and then we delete the original asteroid
and the bullet
and then we do that two more times
with the only real difference being that
the small asteroid doesn't spawn
anything it just gets deleted
we're getting pretty close to this being
asteroids we're just missing a couple of
things the most noticeable one is the
screen wrap
so we're going to create a for each
instance event and for the object picked
this time it'll actually be the group
everything because i put everything in
one group
this game's resolution is 800 by 600 and
because we moved our camera to center on
zero
then we can use this condition
if an object in the group everything
goes beyond 800 in the x direction or
goes behind negative 800 in the x
direction
then it will have its x position times
by negative 1 which will flip it to the
other side
and then we just do the same thing for
the y direction
and now we're almost there
the last thing that's needed for this to
be a game
is a fail state
so we're going to go to the project
manager and look for the extension
health
we'll add that to the project
and now i'll go to the player and select
health
giving it 3 as its total and a 5 second
cooldown until it can be damaged again
then we'll create a tiled sprite
and call it lives
place it in screen into the default
border of the camera
putting it onto the ui layer that i made
earlier
and then we use the physics condition if
the player collides with everything
note that this will ignore the bullet
because the bullet doesn't have the
physics behavior and then we'll add the
action damage player
from the health extension
and then add an action to change the
width of the tile sprite and then we'll
copy that action and put it at the
beginning of scene
so that it modifies the width of the
sprite at the beginning of the scene as
well
and the one last thing we need now is
for the player to die
this specific condition comes from the
health extension and then we'll delete
the player
but on top of that i'm going to create a
text object called game over
and put that on screen and have it hide
during the beginning of the scene and
show up again when the player dies
and that's how long it takes to recreate
asteroids in g develop the only real
problem being that the game doesn't have
any sound and it isn't very much fun to
play
it's technically a game but it's missing
all of its life
we need to add sound effects and screen
shake and particle effects and all that
stuff so let's get started
for now when the player dies they just
get deleted
so instead we're going to create a
particle effect to replace that
we're going to make sure that the ship
has a minimum rotation and that there's
only one particle in tank
and we'll make sure to rotate the
particle so it starts where the player
stopped
and now we have a ship that kind of
falls into space
and we'll use the second particle using
some points
to give it a little more flair
and we could definitely make our game
over text look a little more impressive
so we're going to give it a custom font
this being the font that i use for
everything g developer related
and then if i give it the glitch effect
from the effects menu it will look like
this
which is certainly an improvement
next we're going to create some debris
for the asteroids for when they explode
and just like the ship will be using the
texture of the asteroids to make the
effect
and doing this just makes it more
satisfying to look at when the asteroids
explode
a big problem with this game so far is
the lack of player feedback specifically
when you get hit so we're gonna go to
behaviors and add the flash or blink
behavior to the project
we'll slot that action into the event
where the player gets hurt
and now you can see that the player
flashes when they get hit
another aspect of player feedback would
be sound effects
something that this game really needs
so we're going to open up jfxr
randomize the sound effect until we get
something that we like
and then title it laser fire and save it
you may want to put in a variable for
the sound here but i'm just going to put
in a hard 50 for now
for sounds that happen once in a while
you can just put one here but for sounds
that are going to happen over and over
again you want to have a randomized
pitch
otherwise you're going to drive your
players insane
so to randomize something all we have to
do is type in random and it will show us
our options
and i'm going to pick random float in
range and put in 0.9 and 1.1
this means that every time the sound
effect is played it will pick a number
between 0.9 and 1.1 to play at
i'll slide that action over to where the
laser effect is actually happening
but we're going to do this for
everything in the game which includes a
collision effect when the player runs
into an asteroid and an explosion sound
when the asteroids explode
and now we need just one more thing as
far as effects go and that's the camera
shake
so we're going to add that to the
project
and then go to the getting hurt event
and adding it as an action
and there we go
and now for a little more polish we gave
all the asteroids a bunch of animations
so we're going to go to the beginning of
scene event and use the action change
the number of the animation
and this time we're going to use random
three
because the big asteroid has four
animations and the zero counts as a
number
and now if we start the scene you'll see
that they've all picked a different
image
and now for the somewhat tedious part of
tweaking things
making sure that your collision masks
make sense with the objects and then
play testing it
and then making sure that your speeds
and densities are all the way you want
them
and then you play test it again and
again
and again and again
and again and again
and again
and again and again
and again
and this is a bit subjective but you
keep play testing and tweaking it until
the game feels good to play
now that we've created a game we should
do a few things before we export it so
we're going to go to the properties
manager go to game settings and open up
properties
we're going to give the game the proper
name
give it its version number
change its package name
make sure that you're listed as one of
or the only author
make sure that you've chosen the right
option for how the game should expand in
a screen
and of course for mobile games you want
to make sure that you've chosen your
device's orientation
and finally make sure that you've put in
a publisher name
one more thing to do too is to give your
game icons
all you have to do is click up here
give it a square image and it will turn
that image into an appropriate size for
all the devices
once that's all done we can export our
game
we go up to file
click on export
and right now we're given two options
share with friends
which will give you a link that you can
share with your friends or people that
you want to play test the game
or publish your game
you can build it manually if you know
how
but i'm just going to click on the
button that gets the engine to build it
for you
we're shown 4 different tabs
starting with the web build
which will create a html file that can
be played in browser
next is the mobile export where you can
release an apk to be used on devices
generally
or an android app bundle
which is the kind of bundle that you
need to submit a game to google play
the next type is for exporting a game to
windows linux or mac os
and finally there's instant games
which are posted to facebook with a
facebook developer account
now gdevelop is free entirely free to
use and export from
but there are restrictions for these
automated builds because it costs
gdevelop money to host the servers that
they're built on
so with gdevelop you get two free builds
per day for mobile or desktop
if you pay for a subscription to a g
develop account you get more exports per
day
but
publishing a html build is unlimited
so excuse me for breaking the illusion
for one second
oh no i'm on a regular old pc
okay so we create a new folder
call it game
or whatever your game is called
go back into the engine
click choose folder
find that folder and select it
and then just press export
so now all of the game's files are in
this folder and ready to go all you have
to do is compress it to a zip folder
and that zip folder is your game
but let me quickly show you how to do it
for a pc build
so we go to exports publish to store
make sure that windows auto installer
file is selected and then just click
package
and then you just wait
you'll get this notification here down
at the bottom and if you click that
button you'll get a periodic email that
gives you some stats about your game
and if you just click that windows
button there
it will download to your download folder
and then you'll have your game on your
computer
i hope this video was able to help
anybody out there who wanted to try out
g develop and making their own games but
just didn't know where to start
thank you for watching and best of luck
with your games